une des pires atrocités de l'histoire
contemporaine voilà comment le procureur
du tribunal pénal international avait
qualifié la tragédie de maersk a un
compte de détention installé dans le
nord-ouest de la bosnie en 1992
cet après midi 5 geôliers 1 qu'est ce
terme de bosnie accusé de crimes contre
l'humanité ont été condamnés par ce
tribunal à des peines très lourdes
hervé ghesquière c'est un déni la peine
de 20 ans d'emprisonnement
c'est hésite la pmd 25 ans
d'emprisonnement ces hommes ont été
reconnus coupables de crimes contre
l'humanité et crimes de guerre
le tribunal pénal international de la
haye a également condamné trois autres
serbes de bosnie à tête 6 et 5 ans de
prison
ce procès était celui des responsables
du crabe homard ce cas au nord de la
bosnie en août 1992 le monde découvre
que plus de 3000 musulmans et croates
des scans sont parqués derrière des
barbelés quotidiennement maltraités et
humiliés
des images qui faisait resurgir le
souvenir des épisodes les plus noirs de
la seconde guerre mondiale par ailleurs
les cinq condamnés sont aussi accusés
d'avoir commis des crimes dans deux
autres cas en bosnie toutefois les
grands organisateurs de ces camps et de
la politique de nettoyage ethnique
radovan karadzic et ratko mladic ne sont
toujours pas arrêtés inculpés de crimes
contre l'humanité de crimes de guerre il
échappe encore à la justice
internationale
il se cacherait quelque part en bosnie
au monténégro ou en service